Summertime is here...
...and it might have you longing for the fresh, crisp air of the mountains.
Well, before you head for the hills,...
...here are some packing tips for your flight.
If you're planning a quick day trip,...
...it might not be a bad idea to pack some sunscreen and bug spray.
These liquids must be less than 3.4 ounces and fit inside your one quart size bag per person.
Now, if you're planning on staying a little longer and camping,...
...essentials such as a tent, sleeping bags,...
...flashlights, batteries cooking ware, utensils and matches...
...are all allowed through the security checkpoint.
Trekking poles or hiking sticks of any kind...
...are not allowed through the security checkpoint...
...and must be placed in checked baggage.
Other items you may wish to pack may include a camping stove and fuel.
Now, while the stove is allowed both through the checkpoint and in checked bags,...
...the fuel is prohibited from being carried on or checked,...
...so you should plan on picking that up at your destination.
Flares, fireworks and bear spray are also prohibited...
...in both checked and carry-on bags.